the birth of the universe the Big Bang
was over in a flash
but the death of our universe will take
almost forever that great philosopher of
the Western world
Woody Allen once said eternity
is an awful long time especially toward
the end
figuring out how our universe will end
is as dark a mystery as the Big Bang it
could collapse back in on itself like a
balloon when the air is let out
so at the universe end with a big crunch
a reverse of the Big Bang or was it end
by expanding out and becoming cold and
dark if you wish would it end in fire or
ice or with a bang or a whimper if the
universe collapses it might trigger
another Big Bang
maybe that's already happened
and we're just one in a long line of
universes personally I believe in
continual Genesis that is there's a
never-ending process whereby universes
collides split apart give birth to new
universes perhaps with a different laws
of physics within each universe
maybe this isn't the first time it's
happened maybe it's cyclic and it goes
round and round again eventually will
collapse and the whole thing will start
over again
one universe or many they all start with
a big bang